hey everyone dear fellow here and in
today's video we're going to be power
scaling all of the tokyo revenge's
characters in it list and ranking them
against each other to see who i believe
is the strongest and obviously the
weakest characters in the story that
we've seen so far so this is obviously
going to have spoilers so for anyone who
is an anime only and doesn't want to get
spoiled on you know new characters that
you haven't seen so far in the anime
then do watch it as they are going to be
peppered throughout this entire video
but anyway enough of that must as well
get into this tear list and start
scaling each of these characters so
starting off we have mana and luna which
are obviously mitsuya's sisters and i
decided to stick them at the front
because really honestly we don't know
too much about them and it would be
pretty easy to just stick them straight
in f and say that they you know fodder
easily defeatable and stuff but we
honestly don't have a clue about them
and it is probably just better to stick
them in unknown then stick them in f and
probably step on someone's toes next up
of course we have mitsuya the fourth
division captain of the tokyo manji gang
and obviously being a captain of the
tokyo manji gang he's extremely strong
probably stronger than a majority of the
other captains i believe as well he's
probably stronger than parchin and has
his own like kind of unique fighting
style but then again he's an original
founding member so a lot of the founding
members obviously quite strong
obviously we know he went up against
taiju and was able to actually like
withstand a lot of tajiu's punches to
the point that him and taichi were
almost having some kind of fair fight in
a way so i think matsuya is quite strong
i probably put him at like an a level in
terms of like all the characters and who
else we have coming up throughout the
entire story as i don't believe he is
east here but he's extremely high in a
next up we have parchin so obviously
pachin is the captain of the third
division of the tokyo manchin gang and
probably one of the stronger members
obviously the entire gang as well but
i'd assume that he's probably not the
strongest member out of the five i kind
of point towards the idea that parchin
is probably the weakest out of the five
original founding members which goes
against his entire like look that he
gives off of being this extremely tough
you know scary looking person but
obviously under the surface once you get
to know him he's this really lovely
person so yeah i honestly think sticking
part in like a big tear at the moment
wouldn't be too bad and then if we get
through this and a lot of the other
characters are kind of like filling up
beads here and we might need to stick
par down just because he's conflicting
with a few of the other people then we
can but i think bt for now is a good
spot to stick part in next we have the
first of the meso middle school five so
obviously yamagashi is not strong at all
and in terms of fights i don't actually
think we've seen him really in any fight
apart from the one time that him and the
boys showed up to stop the tomen guys uh
when draken and takamichi were fighting
him so apart from that time i don't
think there is really too much for us to
go off on him he's more knowledge than
fighting at all so i would have to put
yamagashi definitely in like an ft in
terms of strength next up we have tokuya
or yamamoto and obviously
like literally nothing is really known
about his fighting skills in general and
i would assume that he's probably if
anything just slightly stronger than
yamagishi as he is one of the guys i
think that they protect early on because
they're afraid of him getting into a
fight as he's not that strong and he'll
get hurt and i'm pretty sure takamichi
ends up stepping in for him in his fight
so i would assume that he's definitely
like an ft probably even lower than
yamagishi and the idea that he might be
extremely like brittle and take a lot of
damage and get her quite easily next up
we have the man himself though akun who
i think out of the meso middle school
five is definitely the strongest apart
from takamichi i wouldn't put him above
parchin by any means but i definitely
wouldn't be sticking him in like if tear
like a lot of the other guys here and
the meso middle school five are he's
obviously someone who gets manipulated a
lot throughout the entire story and we
don't see a lot of his physical strength
and you know like one of the only fights
that we do see him fighting again is
earlier on in the story where he helps
out takamitsu and then later on in the
tenjiku arc he gets you know badly
beaten up so like from memory he's not
extremely strong and i kind of wouldn't
haven't beaten even a lot of like the
fodder tony members so i probably would
stick him at around like a d tier as
he's not like strong enough to take out
a few toeman members by himself i think
he'd maybe be able to fight like one or
two fodder guys maybe and be able to win
but i think in like a one-on-one with
the photo guy he'd come off on top but
apart from that unlike the other two in
the meso five so far he is a little bit
stronger so we'll put him up indeed here
and then lastly out of the meso five
that we've got here we have masuru and
i honestly i kind of want to stick him
in d as well with a coin but you know
like he is a you know like as they put
it in the story he's a gopher and he
pretty much runs around and pretends to
be the strong guy initially when he
actually isn't i'm gonna stick him at
the top of f tier as he's extremely weak
and i don't think he'd be able to win
against anyone actually by himself in a
fight if it isn't for the help of
yamagishi and yamamoto as well next up
we have the man himself baji kun so
finally the first guy who i would
consider probably like an ester fighter
that we've seen throughout the story he
gets stabbed and then still manages to
take out 50 fodder towing members before
making it to kisaki and finally
collapsing like by far i honestly think
he's probably one of the strongest uh
initial like founding toma members i
think he's probably as strong as
kazatora if not just slightly weaker
so i would stick bhaji though in an east
here because i do believe that bhaji is
an st fighter and he would be able to
beat a lot of the other you know like
vice captains or executives of those
other gangs that we've seen in the past
i think if baji was still around a lot
of these fights that were saying like
say like pay out and have they wouldn't
exactly happen because you know baji
would step in and just take them out
himself but obviously baji isn't here
right now but i would assume that he's
extremely strong baiden s tear
especially with the face that we have
seen him do in the series so far but
moving on from the man bhaji we have
haina and emma up next and i think it's
safe to say that we stick both hana and
emma kind of in the unknown category
just for the idea like unlike yuzuha we
haven't actually seen hina or emma
really fight we've seen him we've seen
him the the mixture of emma and hina
we've seen uh hina slap mikey once but
that was about uh and i don't think
we've actually seen her probably fight
someone whereas with emma i don't think
we've seen her fight someone at all we
might have seen some like kind of
flashback with her in the dojo training
so she might have some kind of fighting
knowledge but from memory uh throughout
the series i don't think we have seen a
fight so i think it's safe to say that
we can stick both hina and emma or
heimer and unknown next up we have the
mysterious shooji hanma and this is
quite a confusing one i was finding it
really hard initially to think where i
was going to stick hanumu because we
haven't really seen a lot from him but
what we have seen from him has been
utterly spectacular he was able to block
two of mikey's kicks and then on the
third one finally when mikey was enraged
because of what had happened to draken
he took him out with like one final kick
and then later on in the arc we have
dracon go up against them and draken you
know ends up winning so i'm assuming
that he definitely is ester and in my
eyes he's probably just stronger than
bhaji so see if him and bhaji had a
fight i feel like hama would just come
out on top because we know that he has
some kind of fighting prowess and he can
take blows he's taken blows from you
know two of the strongest people from
throughout the entire series so far so i
would say it's a good spot to put him up
an estee there next we have rindo and
ran the hatani brothers so obviously
rindo i think is the younger of the two
brothers and honestly these guys here
are super strong but and then again i
don't see them being stf fighters i feel
like render if anything is probably
extremely high beats here with ron being
the stronger fighter out of the two as
it has said in the tenjiku arc the
younger one rindo was the weaker fighter
whereas the the older one ran is the
stronger one so sticky iran i think an a
just below mitsuya is probably a good
spot next up we have osanai so asana was
obviously the leader of mobius which was
the first gang that toman went up
against initially and osana i think i'm
going to stick him and beat here just
above parchin as i don't believe he was
a strong fighter at all he he definitely
outclassed parchin and i think this is
why par needs to be down in seat here as
it would make sense to have him kind of
breaking that middle ground out from who
he couldn't be to you know the people
above um and tobin who could definitely
be osana so it would make sense in my
eyes to have osana in between parchin
and the rest of like toimen above him
next up we have chojo who was a fighter
from valhalla from memory and i'm pretty
sure these next two fighters are both
valhalla fighters that being chome and
jojo and i assume that chima charger we
haven't really seen too much from them
we did see that they were able to grab
mikey when he was in kind of his like
catatonic state and had been hit by that
pole in his head so i would assume that
they're probably around like a seat here
level at the moment just from memory as
they didn't really do too much and when
mikey snapped out of it and like went
into his rage mode he picked both of
them up with like one leg and and
completely smashed them both so yeah
sticking them in seat here kind of below
parchin uh because i feel like
parchin would be able to go up against
one of them by himself and possibly beat
one-on-one but if he was going up in a
like a 2v1 i feel like he would lose in
the situation and lastly but not least
of the valhalla captains we have chonbo
who i think was probably the strongest
out of the three captains that you know
were from valhalla not including baji
and the other guys so i feel like
sticking chambo and kind of like a b
tier would kind of be a fair enough
assessment for his strength as he was
stronger than the other two but probably
not stronger than the leader of mollibus
himself i would assume next up we have i
cannot remember this guy's name off the
top of my head right now but i know he
goes up against payer and uh right at
the start of tenjiku arc
right at the side of the fight of the
tinjiku arc and gets absolutely shocked
oh that's right it's shion matarame
shion you're definitely the original
leader of mobius uh i think uh the
original leader of the ninth generation
black dragons yeah i would assume shion
definitely he was one of the weaker
fighters and i honestly think that shion
could probably even get beaten by
parchin so i'm gonna stick him and sit
here as well just below par next up we
have the first god of the entire scene
the man himself shinocheto sano so
obviously we have no idea how strong
shinichiro sano actually was but if he's
anything like mikey and takamichi mixed
then we know his fighting skills are
absolutely insane along with the fact
that he'll never back down but then
again i don't actually think he has
insane fighting skills i think that he's
just a god for the fact that
everyone looks up to him in the same
kind of way that everyone looks up to
takamichi that's not necessarily how i'm
going to be ranking takamichi in this
list for strength and all that kind of
stuff but for shinachiro just because we
haven't seen anything from him and
because he is this you know like
spiritual figure in the uh series so far
i'm gonna stick him as the god at the
moment next up we have sanzu who's
another extremely mysterious character
whose face isn't actually even seen
until like chapter 206 i believe when he
cuts down the fifth division leader so
i'm assuming sansa was like quite strong
in terms of like mental fortitude and
being able to manipulate people but in
terms of strength though i'm not
actually too sure i know he is going to
be stronger than i would assume probably
like parchin in terms of like actually
fighting we've only ever seen him really
use like a knife to
inflict damage on people apart from in
the first season when we see him fight
for a snippet but yeah so that's kind of
why i would put him in like a bt area
but at the bottom of b uh because he
usually uses weapons to gain an upper
hand on people next up we have kazutora
the man himself and the reason that
mikey almost loses his mind completely i
honestly think khazitora is super strong
the beatdown that he takes from mikey is
like unrelentless and the fact that he
survives or even there long is just
insane so i am going to stick him at the
top of st for the time being just above
hanma as we never got to see those two
kind of go up against each other as they
were technically allied together so we
never really got to see them fight i do
believe though in a battle harma and
khazitora would be extremely interesting
next up we have shifuyu so shifuyu
definitely is a strong fighter but i
wouldn't consider him like an east te
fighter i'd probably put him in the same
tier as a majority of like the other
tomen captains and vice captains and
like atia as he'd probably be able to
beat a majority of the people below him
by himself even if they teamed up with
someone else possibly but i do believe
that shifuyu is an extremely like gifted
fighter and would be able to take down a
lot of the people below him finally the
first girl of the entire series that i'm
actually going to be able to rank in the
tier system and honestly i'm going to
stick user heart in low beat here
because i reckon she could probably beat
the hell out of shion matarame and a few
of those other guys below her along with
the miso middle school five i definitely
could see her defeating and the girls as
well as we've seen her actually kick you
know other people and she has some kind
of like fighting powers to her i wish we
could have seen more but obviously
that's all we're going to get from her
so far in the story and i don't think
we'll get like anything more from her so
yeah i think sticking her in a beat here
is pretty good now this is the first
upset i reckon of the entire night with
kikucho who honestly i consider like
another east here of strength and the
strongest one out of the four that i
have in there at the moment this being
just for the fact that we really haven't
seen his full strength here and he is
absolutely broken what we have seen of
him he was able to take down angry when
he was in his you know like murderous
state so the fact that he was even able
to do that is just insane on itself
alone i'm really wanting to see more
from kokucho and this three deities arc
and at the moment it looks like we're
building up to see some really really
like interesting stuff from him next up
we have the crying blue ogre
angry so angry is definitely going in
est here though i do believe sticking
him below everyone else who is an ester
is pretty fair we do know that he is
stronger than mitsuya and his brother
who i'll grab his brother out now and
stick him in a uh
just below mitsuya because i believe
that that's probably a fair spot to
stick him we haven't seen too much from
smiley but we know smiley is super
strong what we do know for a fact is
that angry when he is in his blue ogre
state is 100 stronger than both masuya
and smiley so i could definitely see him
being an s t character and beating a
majority of the people below him but
only when he's in that tier when he's
not in that tier when angry
isn't in his blue ogre state are
probably going to have to stick him
around the same spot as parchin in a c
tier just because you know he fluctuates
between being this like almost
unstoppable beast to uh just being this
angry guy who really isn't actually that
angry and he's just quite kind and nice
next up we have another
super super strong character that we've
seen a lot of fighting prowess from
throughout the entire story so far that
being izana kurokawa and honestly i'm
going to stick izana up in god's here
because this man compared to every
single person below him at the moment he
would easily be able to beat them uh
probably without a sweat a lot of the
time as well as what we've seen from him
is just utterly insane and i think
putting him up there as one of the
definitive strongest characters in all
of tokyo avengers would actually make
sense
next up we have coco who's another
person who's super mysterious and i want
to see more from and and i would assume
that he's probably on the same level as
the majority of like the other tomen
guys and like just kind of around that
atm mark with him being able to beat
shifuyu probably in a fight and then
some other day shifu you most likely
been able to beat coco in a fight though
i don't see his fighting prowess to be
you know the one thing that he's uh most
valued for obviously when it comes to
like why he's most valued at the end of
the day it's just because he can make so
much damn money next up coco's best
friend in the world in your pay so
anyway i'm going to stick higher than
coco on the list and this is just
because i believe in their fight during
the tenjiku arc uh anupay would have
actually ended up beating coco and it
would just make sense to have and you
pay slightly stronger than coco as
they've kind of always been this duo
together with any pay being the strength
and coco kind of being the smarts of
their little duo now payon definitely i
would consider probably slightly
stronger than parchin surprisingly and
this is just for the fact that he takes
out madarama shion himself and we
actually saw him do it whereas with
parchin we only really ever saw par get
like kind of beating up and then knocked
over and like kind of knocked out and
then have his boys step in for him
whereas with payon we've actually seen
him go up against a bunch of different
people and win like a lot of his fights
so i do believe he's extremely strong
and i'd probably stick him around the
mark of being able to beat sanzu in a
fist fight finally another division
captain of tomen that we've got into
here with uh mucho i believe mucho is
probably insanely strong coming from
that s62 generation so i am going to
stick him up in the eight here above
like obviously coco and you pay and
shifu who he ends up kidnapping
subsequently you know like beating them
up so i would assume that he's obviously
stronger than the people he's beaten up
in the past or caught in the past
next up we have nayoto so naoto we
haven't really ever seen any kind of
fighting prowess from there so he's
never really ever fought anyone and if
anything i would kind of assume that
naoto is more like f or d here than
anything but i'm gonna stick him in
unknown because he is a cop he probably
uses like a gun to fight if anything as
well so i am going to stick him in
unknown for now if anyone thinks any
differently though be sure to chuck a
comment down below and let me know next
up we have two toman fodder guys from
the fight between takamichi drakken and
those tome and photo dudes who are
trying to stop him from the ambulance
and these guys obviously i'm going to
stick them in d tier just above akun
because i believe like by themselves
they would have been able to be akun or
anyone single-handedly but possibly i
couldn't could maybe beat one of them at
the end of the day i'm not really too
sure on their entire like aspect if the
kun really could 1v1 one of these guys
by himself
but i would like to think that he could
oh next up we actually have one of the
meso middle school five i thought we'd
got through all of them but one of them
has managed to weasel his way into the
later group of the entire pack obviously
this here is suzuki and i'm going to
stick suzuki
in detail as well actually because i
believe he is stronger than both masaru
and yamagishi so i think sticking him in
detail would kind of make sense just
slightly weaker than akun who's kind of
the strength leader i would assume of
their like group of five
or next up we have kisaki and this is
probably going to step on a lot of heels
here by honestly i don't think hisaki
was actually that strong if anything
kisaki's like a sea tear in terms of
strength throughout the story probably
not really even being stronger than any
of the people that i've actually already
got and see to hear and would definitely
lose i would say in a hand-hand fight
with any of them the only reason he
comes out on top of it all the time is
because of his manipulation of of other
people and how he sets certain things up
he uses weapons when he can to stab
people or hit people over the head with
poles or use guns to threaten people so
he's just a he's a maniacal character
who will use anything to gain an
advantage in a fight so in terms of like
uh hand-to-hand combat i'm gonna have to
stick him in a c but if if it came down
to any weapon obviously this board would
be completely different and it's it's
really hard to kind of scale anyone
because on a different day it'd be hard
to know who could go up against who and
um actually win
next up we have keramasa the cigarette
smoking thing i'm gonna stick this guy
and seat here also because honestly i
don't believe him to be that strong but
i do think that he is stronger than the
fodder guys that he you know commanded
around who are indeed here um that ran
with him at the beginning of the story
so yeah that would make sense for me
that way um apparently next up we have
coco again somehow so i'm going to stick
coco to the very back of the line or
actually just stick them up in the same
eight here again i think this is just a
two year in the future coco compared to
the slightly younger one moving on to
another of the vice captains from the
tokyo emanji gang hakai so i'm going to
stick hakai
and ate here just below ran because we
know that he was losing in his fight
against ron until angry stepped in and
was able to take him off him if i
remember correctly i might be slightly
wrong on that idea but he was losing in
his fight against ron and i feel like
him probably being the bottom of eight
here would make sense uh maybe just
above coco actually as i think
he's probably the only person in a that
he could be but then again people below
him i could definitely see him beating a
majority of the people below him and
yeah then again we have future and you
pay who will just stick next to it and
you pay again now we have another easter
strength character being taiju obviously
taiju is a complete beast when it comes
to strength i don't know if he'd be
stronger than kokucho because at the
moment it's actually so hard to gauge
how strong kakocho actually is with what
he's done so far we've only seen him
block really someone and then like throw
one kind of punch back but that was
against someone you know like seven
years older than him so he's obviously
not afraid to fight someone a lot older
than who's probably a lot stronger than
him so i think sticking taju and east
here just below kukucho it's probably a
good spot to stick him as i don't think
even hanma would be able to beat taiju
in a one-on-one fight as taiji was just
that strong and
mikey kind of just had to show up and
take him down at the end of the day the
only reason is why i think that mikey
was able to take him down so quickly and
so effortlessly is obviously because
mikey is insane and he's definitely the
strongest person in the entire story but
just for the fact that it also taken so
much damage throughout the night even
takamichi had managed to drop him down
to one knee which is extremely
impressive after all the like batterings
that he'd taken so i just think he's an
insanely strong character like he's the
the sole person they're trying to fight
throughout the entirety of one arc
almost so it's like
four guys on one and he still comes out
on top for a majority of it he's an
insanely strong person and i wouldn't
like ever want to put any of the other
tomen guys and oh 1v1 up against him
next we have kanji one of the executives
of the tenjiku gang so i don't really
know too much about kanji so i'm gonna
stick him and beat here because he gets
like beating quite quickly from memory
so i'm gonna stick him just below rendo
who probably lasted slightly longer than
he did in the fight now moving into you
know kind of more of the unknown-esque
type characters that we really don't
know too much about at the moment who
honestly the majority of these people
here are all going to be east here so if
you're wondering you know like
what i think of of toronto obviously i
think toronto could probably be
anyone that we've seen so far throughout
the story up until this point as the
strongest person that i've got there at
the moment kokocho is underneath him and
i feel like
tirana would have actually had to beat
kokucho in a fight to be able to get him
underneath him so that would just kind
of make sense that he's stronger than
him in that kind of way i'm not going to
put him in god here because we don't
know how strong he is technically and
the only reason he's honored you know
obviously isn't go tears because he was
insanely strong and the fact that he's
passed away just like shinachiro sana
next up though we have wakasa and ben k
so not much is known about both wakasia
and benkei hopefully you know like this
week with where i'm currently up to we
may get a little bit more revealed to us
of these two guys and how strong they
are at fighting exactly but it's all up
in the air and unknown completely at the
moment so i'm gonna stick them kind of
just above
taiju at the moment because they are i
think they're about eight years older
than taiju now when it comes to akashi
here akashi's
so hard to actually gauge on how strong
he is as he's called the god of war so
you would assume him to be this
insanely strong character who could go
up against five people and win and we
have seen him be able to like
obviously run through a bunch of fodder
and take them out but at the moment like
it's a 3v1 of kashi ben k and wakasa
versus south so like those three having
to beat one leader in my eyes it kind of
goes to show that
akashi is more of this leader and he's
has been given the connotation god of
war because he knows how to plan
everything out like ahead of time and
make sure everything's set up in an
exact way that he would like it to be
set up and that's why i believe he's
called the god of war so i'm thinking
that he's much like his sake in terms of
actual strength
but probably because he's eight or nine
years older it's safe enough to say that
he's going to be stronger than a
majority of the people who are actually
here so i think sticking him the top of
eight here at the moment wouldn't
actually be
that bad of a shell
the man himself the goat the one and
only dragon honestly i don't even think
i need to say anything the same
conditions that apply to the other two
sadly now apply to draken he was an
absolute goat and will be remembered as
an absolute goat sorry to spoil anyone
who has been watching this video up
until now and doesn't know about what
happened to draken if you want to know
more go and watch my video on his entire
demise as
it is honestly the saddest death
throughout the entire story so far and
here's a god tear of strength in my eyes
takamichi damn so takaminxi this is kind
of hard to find a spot like where to
stick takamichi exactly because he's
obviously stronger than kisaki in like
terms of fighting statistics and
abilities but he's nowhere near like
stronger than the majority of the people
there i've already got an eight here i
would assume he's not he's always having
to get helped out by like the people who
are in a or ester in his fights so i
think sticking takamichi just above
kanji and beat here wouldn't actually be
a bad spot for him as he's stronger than
kisaki there and it kind of just goes to
show that like yeah takamichi wouldn't
really be able to beat the people above
him in a fight per se
none of them would probably actually be
able to beat takamichi though as at the
end of the day someone is just going to
show up for takamichi and save his ass
and he won't he won't lose until that
person ends up showing up because that's
just takamichi's gimmick he never seems
to back down and no matter how many
times he gets beat into a pulp and never
seems to you know change his
determination anymore and now moving on
we have sinju now sinchu is an extremely
mysterious new character that we don't
really know too much about
the leader of brahman you know the first
female leader of a gang that was seen so
obviously one of the only other females
in all of the tokyo avengers story so
far and honestly
i'm gonna have to stick her and east
here just below toronto because i'm not
sure on her fighting strength just yet
she says that she's able to take down
like and so-and-so or be able to fight
this many people by herself but is she
actually because we don't really know
definitively like whether or not she
actually can we've never seen her win a
fight against anyone yet it's all just
off her words so i really want to see
more and kind of see like how strong she
actually is in these up and coming
chapters hopefully she doesn't get shot
or die um or anything like that too
quickly lastly but not least finally the
man the myth the man himself mikey and
obviously i'm gonna have to stick mikey
right at the top of east here because
mikey is the strongest by far and at the
moment bar maybe toronto or senju i
think mikey could easily beat anyone on
this entire list so i just need to move
baji up to the top real quick because
obviously baji's a god for the fact that
he's passed on now as well so i i should
have remembered that early on
but i think this here pretty much
cements on like my thoughts on who i
think the strongest characters are from
the entire story and who i believe you
know like the weakest characters are in
the entire story and it would kind of
make sense in terms of you know like
people and aids here all being able to
defeat people and beat here and then the
people in bt have been able to defeat
the people and see so on and so on uh
obviously the people in if they fought
the uh unknowns here that would be a bit
of a beat down and be kind of
just completely sad but i don't think
we'll ever see that happen any day
luckily so we can move on from that but
yeah obviously we've got the four gods
at the top and then mikey as the
definitive obviously the strongest
person in all of tokyo revenges or at
least that's what i think in terms of
power he's definitely stronger than
anyone that we've seen so far and i
don't think we've actually even seen you
know the true limits to his power yet or
how strong you possibly be
but anyway what do you guys think of my
uh power scaling careless i guess you
could say be sure to let me know down in
the comment section below and if you
want me to do like more videos like this
on more tier lists and all that kind of
stuff in the future then also let me
know down in the comment section below
and possibly i can do a whole bunch of
like different collaborations with a
whole bunch of like different creators
and we can go over and do a bunch of
different tier lists relating to you
know different tokyo avengers characters
or like specific arcs and all that kind
of jazz be sure to let me know down
below like i've just said twice already
but yeah anyway guys if you are new
around here i want to keep up to date
with the latest tokyo avengers reviews
spoilers and just like other anime
content in general then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
for now it's been a professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit
bye
[Music]
you